Un de leurs aspects est vraiment curieux.
Je sais que vous n'êtes pas fana de polices comme moi.
Certains peut-être, mais rien de grave à ne pas l'être.
Je peux passer des heures chaque jour
à choisir le caractère parfait pour un projet.
Je peux dépenser des sommes énormes tous les ans pour trouver la bonne.
Vous aussi, vous passez des heures à analyser les polices.
Comment êtes-vous arrivés ici ?
Les signes vous ont conduit à évaluer,
sans doute sur votre téléphone,
et déterminer quels signaux suivre et lesquels ignorer.
Vous analysiez les polices.
Quand vous achetez un nouveau produit,
vous réfléchissez si c'est cher,
ou bon marché, facile à acheter, ou pas.
Ce qui est curieux,
et ça pourrait ne pas vous paraître insolite,
mais à l'instant où une chose semble étrange,
vous la détectez immédiatement.
(Rires)
J'aime la typographie,
et les polices, et Futura,
parce que l'objet de mon étude est présent partout.
Les rues que je parcours, les livres que je touche,
tout ce que je lis est imprégné de l'objet de ma passion.
Dès qu'on a la compréhension de l'histoire et de ce qui arrive avec les typographies,
on a sous les yeux l'histoire de tout.
Voici la police Futura.
Comme je vous l'ai dit, c'est du modernisme minimaliste.
Elle a catalysé la diffusion du modernisme dans notre pays
et est devenue la police la plus populaire et la plus omniprésente
du XXe siècle.
« Moins, c'est mieux, » une des maximes du modernisme.
Le même phénomène est apparu dans les arts visuels.
Observons les basiques, les formes de base,
la géométrie.
Futura y est très attachée.
Vous remarquerez que les formes inhérentes de Futura
sont des cercles, des carrés, des triangles.
Certaines formes sont basées sur le cercle,
le O, le D ou le C,
et d'autres ont la pointe du triangle.
D'autres encore semblent avoir été conçues avec une règle et un compas.
Elles paraissent géométriques, mathématiques et précises.
En fait, ce système est prégnant dans la conception de la police.
Pour ne pas ressembler à une autre police et être totalement neuve.
La voici avec des graisses légères, moyennes et grasses.
La famille de police est composée de différents éléments.
C'est en rupture consciente avec le passé
car elle semble avoir été conçue par une machine, et non à la main.
À la main signifie ceci.
C'est ce que nous imaginons souvent
quand on pense à une police calligraphiée au pinceau ou au stylo :
l'épaisseur des traits varie.
Des polices plus traditionnelles, comme Garamond,
conservent ces vestiges du passé
où le sommet du A est légèrement plus fin
et sa base est plus épaisse,
pour ressembler à une forme manuscrite.
Mais Futura a été conçue
pour donner l'impression qu'aucun homme n'y a touché,
qu'une machine l'a conçue,
pour une ère industrielle de la machine.
La dextérité de la main y est toutefois présente.
Paul Renner, le graphiste qui a conçu Futura en 1927, y a veillé.
Quand on observe comment
la forme circulaire rejoint le fut vertical,
on constate un léger biseautage.
C'est une des centaines de manières
qui donnent aux polices une apparence géométrique parfaite,
mais pas mathématiquement parfaite.
C'est ce que font les graphistes tout le temps
pour réussir leurs polices.
D'autres graphistes y ont aussi réfléchi en Europe et en Amérique.
Il y a eu quelques très bons exemples en Europe
de tentatives pour créer des choses neuves pour une ère nouvelle.
On en trouve en Allemagne,
d'une certaine manière, semblables à Futura,
mais avec un centre de gravité et des proportions différents.
Pourquoi Futura a-t-elle conquis le monde ?
Dans ce cas-ci, le nom des polices est parfois difficile à prononcer :
Erbar, Kabel Light, Berthold-Grotesk, Elegant-Grotesk.
Ce ne sont pas des mots courants.
En comparaison, Futura,
on constate que l'équipe marketing a fait un choix judicieux.
Ce qui est incroyable avec ce nom,
tout ce que contient le nom,
c'est l'évocation de l'espoir et d'une idée de ce que sera l'avenir.
Ce n'est même pas le mot allemand pour avenir.
Ce n'est pas un mot en allemand, ils ont choisi un terme
qui ferait écho chez un public plus large et universel.
Comparons-la à ce qui se faisait aux États-Unis.
Voici des polices étasunienne de la même époque, les années 20,
Bold, Brash, Braggadocios.
Elles évoquent les fluctuations erratiques des marchés financiers
dans les années 20.
La comparaison met en avant le côté révolutionnaire de Futura.
J'aimerais prendre du recul et montrer l'usage d'une police.
Nous connaissons tous ce magazine : « Vanity Fair ».
Voici sa mise en page, à l'été 1929.
Il n'y a rien hors du commun dans son graphisme.
C'est très typique des années 20.
Il y a la photo d'un homme important,
Franklin Roosevelt ici, alors gouverneur de New York.
Tout est centré et symétrique.
Il reste quelques ornements,
sans doute les vestiges de l'époque victorienne,
pas encore totalement moderne.
Mais tout paraît robuste.
Il y a même des lettrines, pour guider le lecteur.
Mais tout ça a changé brusquement en octobre 1929.
Un graphiste de Berlin a redessiné « Vanity Fair ».
Voici sa mise en page avec Futura.
Pour remplacer le gouverneur,
on a une photo abstraite et magnifique,
l'océan, ici.
Les lettrines ont disparu.
L'asymétrie remplace la pagination centrée.
Plus on lit, plus le graphisme devient radical,
Ici, avec l'asymétrie.
Les illustrations de Pablo Picasso se meuvent dans la page,
ignorant la gouttière entre les deux pages.
Il y a plus radical encore.
En observant attentivement, on constate une chose :
c'est presque imperceptible,
mais il n'y a pas de majuscules dans les titres et les chapeaux.
Ça peut vous sembler peu remarquable,
mais quel que soit le magazine ou le site Internet,
vous n'en trouverez pas facilement sans de lettre capitale.
C'est une idée révolutionnaire.
Pourquoi ?
Car le sens véhiculé par les lettres capitales
dénote quelque chose d'important,
qu'il s'agisse de notre nom ou de nos titres.
Ou du nom de nos entreprises,
voire des marques.
D'une certaine manière, l'Amérique est la patrie de la lettre capitale.
On adore utiliser des capitales partout.
(Rires)
Imaginez combien il est révolutionnaire
de diffuser un magazine qui a retiré toutes les lettres capitales.
Ça a dû avoir le même impact politique
que nous octroyons aujourd'hui à des éléments comme le genre des pronoms.
Les années 20,
ce sont les années qui suivent la révolution communiste en Russie.
Ce graphisme représente l'infiltration du socialisme aux États-Unis.
Les minuscules signifient l'égalitarisme,
l'abaissement complet de tout sur ce terrain d'égalitarisme.
C'est là qu'est l'idée révolutionnaire.
Pensez à comment les lettres capitales
confèrent du pouvoir, du prestige aux choses.
Pour ces gens, Futura véhiculait cette idée à travers ce moyen.
D'autres graphistes ont utilisé Futura autrement,
et lui ont attaché d'autres idées du modernisme,
que ce soit avec des nouveaux styles d'illustration,
ou des illustrations donnant l'illusion de collage.
Ou des nouvelles couvertures de livres provenant d'Europe.
Le sel de la typographie dans les années 20,
c'est que pour utiliser une nouvelle police,
on ne pouvait évidemment pas la télécharger.
On avait besoin de pièces en plomb.
Les Américains qui voulaient l'adopter
et l'intégrer dans leur propre système,
en tant qu'élément typographique ordinaire,
dans des publicités ou tout autre support,
devaient posséder des poinçons.
En tant que parfaits capitalistes, qu'ont fait les Américains ?
On a fait plein de copies.
Des copies sans rien à voir avec le nom Futura
mais qui lui étaient identiques,
que ce soit Spartan ou Tempo.
Quand la Deuxième Guerre mondiale a commencé,
les entreprises américaines essayaient de boycotter les produits nazis.
Elles ont proposé d'utiliser les copies américaines :
« Utilisez 20th Century, Spartan, Vogue ou Tempo.
Elles sont identiques à Futura. »
On ne prenait même pas la peine d'utiliser le nouveau nom.
On continuait de les appeler Futura.
Bref, les Américains ont adopté cette police,
ils l'ont conquise et se la sont appropriée.
À la fin de la guerre,
les Américains l'utilisaient partout,
dans les catalogues, les atlas,
les encyclopédies, dans des tableaux, des graphiques,
des calendriers, des tracts politiques,
pour les logos des nouvelles équipes de football
et même pour certaines des publicités les plus influentes du XXe siècle.
C'est dans ce contexte d'après-guerre que le gouvernement américain,
au moment de choisir une police pour ses cartes et ses projets,
a choisi Futura.
Ce n'était pas un choix étonnant ou radical.
Ça n'avait rien à voir avec le communisme.
Mais on l'a utilisée sur les cartes les plus importantes,
comme cette carte de l'armée de l'air en 1962,
ou ces cartes utilisées au Vietnam en 66.
Ce n'est donc pas surprenant
qu'au moment où les astronautes ont initié le programme Mercury,
lançant John Glenn en orbite autour de la Terre,
Futura soit sur les tableaux et cartes.
Quand Mercury est devenu Apollo,
le projet intégrait de plus en plus de ses éléments.
Ici, par exemple, le plan de sécurité,
les tableaux de bord,
les aides à la navigation.
Même les diagrammes représentant le fonctionnement du système.
Ce qui est encore plus incroyable,
c'est que Futura n'a pas uniquement envahi les documents.
On a commencé à l'utiliser comme interface
d'un système qui aidait les astronautes à manipuler les instruments.
La NASA n'était pas une grande entreprise produisant tout en interne.
Il y avait des centaines de sous-traitants,
Boeing, IBM, McDonnell Douglas, qui fabriquaient des équipements.
Que se serait-il passé si les astronautes avaient dû user des polices différentes
pour chaque composant de leur navette ?
Ça aurait été impossible de naviguer et ils auraient eu une surcharge cognitive
chaque fois qu'ils utilisaient un nouveau système.
Dès lors, Futura, en devenant leur interface,
les a aidés à gérer la complexité en la clarifiant.
Futura était sur les boutons, les étiquettes,
les rations alimentaires,
et les boîtes à outils.
Elle expliquait comment utiliser les manettes et les leviers de commande.
Dans des endroits où des choses complexes devaient apparaître simplement,
les instructions étaient imprimées en Futura,
pour leur permettre de savoir quoi faire à ce moment précis.
Inutile de tout mémoriser,
tout était apparent, écrit et lisible pour tous.
Futura a contribué à mettre sur pied ce système,
à rendre ce système très complexe et difficile à naviguer,
un peu moins complexe.
D'ailleurs, la première et dernière chose qu'un astronaute voyait
au moment d'entrer ou de sortir de sa navette
était sans doute du Futura.
Un de mes exemples favoris sur l'impact de Futura
est cet appareil photo.
C'est un Hasselblad conçu par une entreprise suédoise.
C'est un très bon boîtier que vous avez peut-être utilisé vous-même.
C'est un objet de qualité très apprécié des photographes.
Si vous vous y connaissez un peu en appareil photo,
vous aurez remarqué quelques modifications :
Les étiquettes sur les boîtiers des films
et sur d'autres parties du boîtier.
Ça a permis à la NASA
de tirer le meilleur, l'extraordinaire, de ses astronautes.
Les astronautes ne sont ni photographes, ni artistes.
Ils voulaient que les astronautes utilisent correctement l'appareil photo
guidés par des notices en Futura.
Dans ce cas précis, Futura leur a permis de gagner la légitimité
pour manipuler les objets qui leur avaient été confiés.
Par exemple, éviter de retirer le film avant son exposition.
Sans cela, nous n'aurions jamais obtenu certaines de leurs photos incroyables.
En observant un objet décoratif, comme cet écusson commémoratif,
ou cette plaque laissée sur la Lune,
on comprend que Futura transcendait le cérémonial,
que c'était davantage qu'un simple graphisme.
Futura avait en fait autorité,
légitimité et pouvoir, puisqu'elle avait été choisie.
J'aimerais conclure avec ceci :
Futura nous raconte une histoire.
C'est ça qui me passionne, toutes les polices relatent un récit.
Futura relate l'histoire particulièrement marquante
de l'assimilation d'un élément importé aux États-Unis
et qui est devenu une partie intégrante de sa culture.
C'est là où l'Amérique excelle, pour le meilleur et pour le pire :
nous assimilons des choses à notre culture
puis nous les recrachons tout en les revendiquant.
Futura reflète ce qui s'est passé avec cette technologie
soutenant un système entier.
Futura est une police allemande que nous avons assimilée
avant d'en faire un produit de base.
D'autres technologies aussi :
les fusées et les scientifiques venaient tous d'Allemagne.
Une police allemande sur une plaque américaine
reflète parfaitement le sort de cette technologie.
Dans ce cas,
l'histoire nous permet de prendre conscience que la police sur la Lune
représente la légitimité et l'autorité
et que cela leur a offert le pouvoir d'aller sur la Lune.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)